why do we cross mile why do we cry
humans are the only animals that cry and
scientists believe that the response
developed as an automatic way to signal
to others our distress watery eyes our
bodies throwing up a white flag and
breaking any eye contact that could be
interpreted as competitive why do I cry
when I'm happy the tiny part of your
brain that controls emotional responses
can't tell the difference between being
happy or sad it just knows that you're
overwhelmed although we associate tears
with sadness crying is basically an
expression of vulnerability when I'm
embarrassed why do I blush when you're
embarrassed your body releases
adrenaline which triggers the veins in
your face it's believed that we
developed blushing as a physical apology
for our mistakes for yours and our
vision may have actually evolved to
better detect color changes in skin when
I get nervous why do I get butterflies
in my stomach when you're faced with an
intense situation you're by prepares
itself to act increasing breathing and
blood flow as a result blood flows away
from your stomach and out to your lungs
and muscles why do we smile we smile
because it makes us feel good when you
smile it causes activity in the brain's
reward circuits and when you smile along
with a friend it activates the circuits
that control social bonding what do we
laugh
scientists believe that laughing started
as a way for humans to communicate a
false alarm
which explains I'll be laughing someone
falls but is okay
laughter the expression of relief at a
dangerous situation has turned out okay
Oh